[Music]
will her new foreign policy class change
Minds that she's a horse's ass
this week Columbia University shared a
video promoting a new course that's
co-taught by Hillary Clinton believe me
no one's more thrilled to have Hillary
out of the house than Bill
speaking of Bill if you're a lady who
was a solid eight or above he'll tutor
you for free
the course he's teaching how to fit
snugly under my desk
oh I know terrible huh the school says
the class is called inside the situation
room and will examine decision making in
a variety of historical and contemporary
contexts from the search for bin Laden
to the red line in Syria to negotiating
with Iran roll it
oh my God what is it it's Hillary
Clinton she's running what
[Music]
what Hillary's running again I know
this is wild she's running again
[Music]
you're running again
well I sure am Karen I just got here
early for the new class we're teaching
together on foreign policy decision
making
oh that's awesome
it's so clever she's running again
the only thing missing was music from
psycho and like most things Hillary's
involved with it gets worse
you know when it comes to crisis
situations you've always got to be
prepared prepared I think you're more
prepared than anyone to teach this
course and I'll cover the theory of
political decision making and strategy
and I'll cover what it was actually like
in the room during the bin Laden raid
the Iran sanctions the Gaza ceasefire
you name it okay but are you ready for
whatever questions the students throw at
you bring it on
Bring It On
I wonder what it is her bleached server
or bleached mustache
now maybe it's me but I don't think that
video really captured the charm of
Hillary the power of her persuasion the
gift of her insight and wisdom so we
improved it
oh my God what is it it's Hillary
Clinton she's running what
[Music]
what Hillary's running again that old
bag who destroyed Libya this is wild
she's running again what isn't that the
lady that killed Jeffrey Epstein
[Music]
you're running again
foreign
if you were a student if you were a
student in her class what would you ask
her I wouldn't be this would be the
easiest class really I would love to
take this class well it'd be so easy why
if I don't know if on a test you had
some kind of like foreign policy
situation you know who's grading you so
you just write do a war yeah
or sometimes maybe like do an act of War
but then insist that it wasn't one and
then tell her how inspiring she is yes
boom a plus you have to go one time and
do that and then you would never have to
do any work again she wants she wants to
feel like she's an inspiring these young
people I don't think she does but as
long as they understand that's what she
wants that's how they can get an A did
you like the gag I'm running that was
great you have to right what a Twist
listen listen I'm
they obviously don't like her yeah okay
through this commercials
okay first of all the stunt double
running for yeah well dude wait that was
that I mean we know she is cankles Okay
so
The Skinny Legs skinny pants running
swiftly to the classroom the pants
didn't even match
we should have been a pantsuit
into acting it was all one taste but you
have to drop when you have to use a
stunt double to run three steps to
simulate a light jaw maybe you ditch the
running bit
maybe you rewrite the running bit or the
fact that somebody was actually on a
Blackberry going she's running again
like this is the worst commercial I've
ever hey hate her like there's no way
that after that first take of
yeah I'm early I'm running again nobody
was cut beautiful you wanna do it again
no perfect like she has zero personality
the only thing that was good about this
one is her daughter wasn't in it with
her that was the only thing that was
different she found a way to cut her out
selfish you know that other lady Joe
that other lady there is going to do all
the work right it's it's well yes I do
think that I wrote a lot of jokes about
this I'm glad you finally came to me yes
uh and I need to make Hillary jokes to
get everybody back on my side
like either side all right I'm miserable
I just anyway
uh her Hillary's performance in this
video was more heartbreaking to me than
Brendan Fraser's in the whale first of
all
listen folks I got more
uh that's the classes
the class is called Inside The Situation
Room which sounds like what Matt Lauer
would say to a woman after he remotely
locked his door
but no here's the thing
uh
here's the thing I the thing that annoys
me most about this stupid thing first of
all I hate I hate anybody acting like a
presidential candidate former or
president whatever gets them I hate this
whole thing to be Hillary's running
we're so excited they don't get you yeah
they don't it's literally like saying
you know it's down to earth Tom Cruise I
gotta tell you he's such a normal guy
it's an idiotic thing to think yeah but
my point is uh with this class what
really bothers me more than anything is
I don't want a class where you're
telling everybody what went on in The
Situation Room people in this country
can't watch a football game without
jumping on Twitter and saying exactly
how it should have been done and with
zero expertise now you're going to open
up hey here's how here's how we captured
Bin Laden so so then the morons can sit
there and go well you should have done
what did they do but it also got show
just how far the um the grift for her
and for Bill Clinton has fallen you know
had she been re-elected you know they
once had the Clinton Global initiative
yeah which was raking in hundreds of
millions of dollars from all over the
world and now she's like trying to
squeeze something together to get like a
college course at Columbia University
with a professor named Karen and uh
and who spells her name
k-e-r-e-n is there anything more Karen
than somebody spelling their name Karen
wrong what if what if but what if she's
from another country like is that how
you spell everybody in that commercial
was from another country they couldn't
even vote
it really was like a Benetton ad for old
people
but what do you think the rub is here
what do you think ah peps Bill's
favorite question
oh not from Hillary yeah
there we go all right
you got it
a win Joe wins the audience back to his
side I knew I could get it sandwiches
for everybody those of you at home that
say I should quit comedy that was an
Applause break
no no but
but
I'm really asking what like what does
she gain from doing this that's I'm very
very bored she can't go home because
whenever she goes home Bill's lying
there buck naked with like four flight
attendants
no no actually
she's trying to run again no it's it no
I gotta go
no one at home is going to hear that no
no they are they're just gonna say four
flight attendants and they bleep out the
rest of it
yeah
all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else